[Musik]
bismark erst ist die blm juni beginnt
mit einleitung und vorbemerkungen das
ist zb der teil der uns beschäftigen
wird diese woche und auch noch nächste
woche danach wird es dann weitergehen zu
dem was man aussagen logik nennt ich
hätte jetzt noch gar nicht was das
eigentlich heißen soll
aber sie sehen die teile analyse
repräsentieren sprache semantik
herleiten
und dann kommt noch so ein appendix und
dann beginnt die prädikaten logik so
ungefähr in der mitte der vorlesung und
dann sehen sie so ähnliche ausdrückliche
repräsentieren wie der sprache semantik
herleiten wir so ein appendix und das
deutet schon darauf hin dass die
vorlesung im wesentlichen aus zwei
großen lücken bestehen wird
nach dem kriminellen die uns im
folgenden beschäftigen werden gibt es
den aussagen logik block und den
prädikaten logik block und die sind
ziemlich ähnlich strukturiert man könnte
sagen dass wir in der logik alles
zweimal machen einmal auf aussagen
logischen niveau das ist das einfachere
niveau und dann auf prädikaten logischen
niveau das ist das komplexere niveau und
das hat den vorteil dass vieles was
vielleicht am anfang noch ein bisschen
unklar bleiben wird in der aussage logik
dann wenn wir zur privaten logik
schreiten schon vertraut sein wird ja
und durch die wiederholung noch mal
klarer wird ja und dann kann man auch
einiges vertiefen und das passiert dann
in der prädikaten gruppe
dass die logik diesen sicheren gang
schon von den ältesten zeiten her
gegangen sei lässt sich daran ersehen
dass sie seitdem aristoteles keinen
schritt rückwärts hat tun dürfen
merkwürdig ist noch an ihr dass sie auch
bis jetzt keinen schritt vorwärts hat
ruhen können
und also allem anschein nach allen
ansehen nach geschlossen und vollende zu
sein schaffen
die grenze der logik aber ist dadurch
ganz genau bestimmt dass sie eine
wissenschaft ist welche nichts als die
formalen regeln des denkens es mag a
priori oder empirisch seinen ursprung
oder objekt haben welches es wolle
in unserem gemüte zufällige oder
natürliche hindernisse antreffen
ausführlich darlegt und strenge beweist
dass es kalt und der kritik der reinen
vernunft
in deutschland muss man alle philosophie
vorlesungen immer mit einem kann zitat
bedienen das ist der grund warum ich so
starte und sie sehen in diesem ersten
abschnitt hier zweierlei erstens kann
bezieht sich auf aristoteles und ganz zu
recht denn die logik hat begonnen mit
aristoteles mit dem was man an
historisches die logistik nennt und das
ist ein einfaches logisches system für
eine einfache logische sprache eine
sprache die viel einfacher ist als die
formalen sprache die wir im rahmen
dieser vorlesung kennen lernen die
sprache für die der aristoteles logik
entwickelt hat ja wäre viel zu
eingeschränkt um in die wissenschaft
betreiben zu können
die sprache für die wir logik betreiben
werden im rahmen dieser vorlesung ist
ausreichend für die gesamte mathematik
zum beispiel für praktisch die gesamten
naturwissenschaften und für einen
großteil der philosophie also kurz
gesagt unsere logik ist viel cooler als
die von paris titel ist aber das ist ja
auch schon lange her und ist eine
unglaubliche gewaltige leistung gewesen
ist alles total ist logik auf die weise
zu beginnen
ja und wenn man sich das genauer
anschaut logan aristoteles verwendet
bereits logisch symbole also formale
zeichen und sie werden einige diesen
formalen zeichen dann in ähnlicher form
wiederfinden
im rahmen unserer vorlesung er
beschäftigt sich mit syntax er
beschäftigt sich mit semantik er
beschäftigt sich mit der leitungs regeln
und genau das werden wir auch tun
ja das ist der erste punkt ihren und der
zweite punkt den sie hier sehen bei kant
ist er sagt also die logik beginnt mit
aristoteles und mehr oder weniger
seltsamerweise hört sich auch schon
wieder damit auch denn sie scheint
irgendwie vollendet und abgeschlossen zu
sein und das war aus sicht von kant
richtig denn bis zur krankheit wenige
weiterentwicklung geben in der logik im
vergleich zu es tote lässt aus heutiger
sicht ist es völlig falsch
die logik ist geradezu explodiert aber
das war nach kant fairerweise er und
zwar ist die logik explodiert im
neunzehnten jahrhundert und dann erst
recht im zwanzigsten jahrhundert und das
was wir hier als logik betreiben werden
ist logik wie sie entwickelt wurde
in dieser neueren entwicklung ja vor
allen dingen im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
an die grenze der logik schreibt sich
auch ist aber dadurch ganz genau
bestimmt dass sie eine wissenschaft ist
klar welche nichts als die formalen
regeln des denkens ausführlich darlegte
strenge beweisen und das ist immer noch
richtig ja was er hier die formalen
regeln des denkens nennt werden wir bald
umschreiben mit hilfe von logischer form
und hier leitungs regel ja wir werden
die logische form von natur sprachliche
setzen festlegen
und sobald uns das gelungen ist wird es
uns möglich sein hier leitungen
durchzuführen festzustellen was aus
gewissen setzen natürliche sprache
logisch folgt ja und diese regeln nach
denen diese folge vonstatten gehen wird
werden nur abhängig sein von der
logischen form dieser sätze und insofern
werden diese regeln formal sein
ja das ist immer noch so wie es kannte
gesehen hat das denken schreibt ist mag
a priori oder empirisch sein falls
jemand von ihnen was was er mit aprimo
remind
vor der erfahrung werden die wörtliche
übersetzung genau und das stimmt auch
man sollte nur vor nicht zeitlich lesen
sondern eher im sinne von unabhängig von
erfahrung also eine erkenntnis ist a
priori genau dann wenn sie unabhängig
von sinneserfahrung rechtfertigbar ist
zb gehen sie in eine mathematik
vorlesung dort wird irgendein satz
bewiesen dann rekurriert dieser beweis
an keiner stelle auf sinneserfahrung ja
der mathematiker oder die mathematikerin
wird nie sagen und dann führen sie
dieses experiment durch und schauen
genau hin und so weiter und daraus folgt
dass ja das ist genau das was die
mathematiker nicht tun sondern die
rechtfertigen ihre sätze durch beweise
apriori unabhängig von sinneserfahrung
naturwissenschaften hingegen
typischerweise produzieren wenn sie
erkenntnisse produzieren aproz theorie
oder empirische erkenntnisse
erkenntnisse die man nicht rechtfertigen
könnte ohne sinneserfahrung den messen
ohne experimente und erlöschen
und was kann hier sagt es egal ob das
denken apriori ist wie zum beispiel in
der mathematik oder in der philosophie
oder usa postareal empirisch ist wie zum
beispiel in den naturwissenschaften
egal die regeln der logik sind immer
dieselben die sind sozusagen universell
die funktionieren überall und das ist
auch aus heutiger sicht nach wie vor
richtig
ich habe den eindruck dass die logik die
in den schulen vertreten wird so weit
von jener logik entfernt ist die
nützlich für die leitung des geistes
hinsichtlich der erforschung der
verschiedenen wahrheiten ist wie sich
die knaben arithmetik von der algebra
eines bedeutenden mathematikers
unterscheidet also hier steht okay die
logik die in den schulen vertreten wird
das war zu diesem zeitpunkt werde gleich
sehen dass es leid netz der hier spricht
das war zu diesem zeitpunkt immer noch
die aristotelische logik die dann in das
plastik wieder revitalisiert wurde und
so weiter und leidend sachs und dieser
logik von der westfälischen logik dass
sie ist besonders nützlich ist die ist
so ähnlich nützlich wie knaben
arithmetik als heutiger sicht übrigens
nicht mehr politisch korrekt haben oder
mädchen arithmetik und diese
unterscheidet sich von der algebra eines
bedeuteten mathematikers oder einer
bedeutenden mathematikerin soll heißen
ja genauso einfach ja wie
schulmathematik ist ja genauso einfach
ist auch die aristotelische logik das
was man in der mathematiker wirklich
bräuchte ist die entwickelte mathematik
in der höheren algebra zum beispiel und
entsprechend bräuchte man und darauf in
leibnitz hinaus auch eine logik die auf
ähnlichem niveau stattfindet aber
bräuchte eine logik die zuhörer algebra
steht sowie aristotelische logik
einfache logik zu einfacher mathematik
und dann sagt er das ist absolut möglich
so etwas zu entwickeln
im privaten bereich aber ist es höchste
zeit dass fachleute der analytik eine
logik zur vollendung bringen
die geeignet ist die einzelnen
untersuchungen zu leiten also einen
leitfaden des denkens das soll die logik
sein
da nämlich heutzutage ein so
umfangreiches material hervorragender
gedanken vorhanden ist bleibt es nur
noch übrig diesen eine form zu verleihen
gewissem sinne ist es also so die
wissenschaften zusagen für den stoff
ja und die logik sorgt für die form
organisiert das wissen sozusagen
aufrichtige art und weise einen
leitfaden des denkens aber nenne ich
eine bestimmte leichte und sichere
methode mit der wir wenn wir ihr folgen
ohne beunruhigung des geistes ohne
streitigkeiten ohne furcht zu irren
nicht weniger sicher voranschreiten als
jemand der im labyrinth einen ariadne
faden zur verfügung hat und ich meine
dass eine solche methode in unserer
macht steht und mit nicht allzu große
schwierigkeit erstellt werden kann und
dass diese so evident sein wird dass sie
alle kontroversen ohne widerspruch
beendet ganz und gar sowie jene
kontroversen die im bereich der zahlen
kühle auftreten können von einem
erfahrenen arithmetischer entweder
alleine oder und durch hinzuziehung
eines mitarbeiters ohne schwierigkeit
beendet werden ich meine dass der
gebrauch dieser methode unter die
höchsten güter zu ziehen ist die dem
menschengeschlecht zuteil werden könnten
also kurz gesagt diese logik immer
wirklich bräuchte für die wissenschaften
die gibt es noch nicht aber wir sind
knapp davor sie zu entwickeln schreibt
bleiben jetzt und mit knapp davor
wir sind knapp davor sich zu entwickeln
meinte er ist knapp davor zu entwickeln
und es gibt interessante
interessanterweise wirklich versuche von
leibnitz zu einer logik zu entwickeln
er war jetzt nicht ganz knapp dran an
logik im modernen sinne ja aber er war
sozusagen ganz klar auf der richtigen
spur
er schlägt vor so etwas wie eine
charakteristika universal ist eine
universal zeichensprache zu entwickeln
in der man alle erkenntnisse der
wissenschaften ausdrücken kann
und zwar so ausdrücken kann dass diese
erkenntnisse ganz präzise und
transparent gefasst werden können
also wo man über irgendeinen einzelne
dinge in der welt spricht entspricht
diesem einzel in der sprache genau ein
zeichen wo man über eine bestimmte
eigenschaft oder beziehungen von dingen
in der welt sprechen möchte entspricht
diese eigenschaft oder dieser beziehung
wieder genau ein entsprechendes zeichen
in der sprache also die sprache spiegelt
sozusagen die wirklichkeit eins zu eins
und ganz
transparent wieder und zu dieser
charakteristika universalist soll es
noch einen kalkulation ator geben und
das ist das was wir heute einfach einen
logischen kalkül oder eine logische her
leitungs ordnung oder ein logisches
regelsystem nennen also ein quasi
mechanisches regelsystem indem man
erkenntnisse berechnen kann
so ähnlich wie man setze beweist in der
arithmetik unterzahl agieren
und wenn sich zwei zb philosophen
streiten ist das was sie tun sollen sagt
leith netz sich hinzusetzen mit einem
blatt papier oder einem ipad und rechnen
ja also er sagt kalkuhl muss rechnen wir
lösen wir die widersprüche die
philosophischen widersprüche dadurch auf
dass wir rechnen mit dieser methode in
dieser universellen zeichensprache und
das ist im prinzip genau das was wir tun
werden im rahmen dieser vorlesung also
wir werden eine art universelle
zeichensprache entwickeln mit der man im
wesentlichen alle wissenschaftlichen
gedanken ausdrücken kann und zwar mit
maximaler präzision und dann werden wir
eine einen kalkuhl uns dazu entwerfen
mit deren mit dessen hilfe man quasi
mechanisch aus wissenschaftliche setzen
andere wissenschaftliche setzte ableiten
kann mit der man quasi mechanisch
feststellen kann ob sich zwei
wissenschaftliche sätze oder auch zwei
philosophische setzte ob die zueinander
im widerspruch stehen und dergleichen
also im wesentlichen ist das was wir in
dieser vorlesung durchführen werden so
etwas wie die vollendung des leibniz
zentrums und der schluss das heißt dass
logik ganz tolles weil die höchsten
güter die dem menschengeschlecht zuteil
werden können wie muss ich denken um das
ziel die wahrheit zu erreichen
die beantwortung dieser frage erwarten
wir von der logik aber wir verlangen
nicht von ihr dass sie auch das
besondere jedes wissens gebietes und
deren gegenstände eingehen sondern nur
das allgemein sste was für alle gebiete
des denkens geltung hat
zugeben weisen wir der logik als aufgabe
zu die regeln für unser denken und für
wahr halten müssen wir bestimmt denken
durch die gesetze des rasens mit diesen
sind jene gegeben
wir können mithin auch sagen die logik
ist die wissenschaft der allgemeinen
gesetze des rasens das ist jetzt fliege
deutscher logiker und philosoph und
mathematiker wenn es eine begründer der
modernen logik gibt dann gottlob frege
ja der in seiner begriffs schrift so ein
kleines bändchen im wesentlichen als
erster diese leibliche idee wirklich
umgesetzt hat und im prinzip die moderne
logik so wie wir sie heute kennen
entwickelt hat natürlich ist danach dann
noch sehr viel passiert ja aber der
beginn der modernen logik ist pflege und
er charakterisiert logik nicht unähnlich
zukommt logik dreht sich um die
allgemeinen gesetze des rasens die ids
wahrheit ist ohnehin das wissenschafts
ziel also wissenschaften sollen
feststellen welche sätze waren und
welche falsch physiker tun dies in der
physik da gibt es also um physikalische
wahrheiten und mathematiker tun das in
der mathematik da geht es um
mathematische wahrheiten und historiker
tun dies ja in den
geschichtswissenschaften dort geht es um
historische wahrheiten und so hat jedes
gebiet seine eigenen wahrheiten die
logik beschäftigt sich aber mit den
gesetzen der wahrheit die universellen
sind ja die in allen diesen gebieten
gleichermaßen vorhanden sind und das ist
ein gedanke so ähnlich wie vorher
bekannt ja egal ob a priori oder
imperial logik gilt überall das ist
derselbe gedanke ja logik beschäftigt
sich mit den allen die meisten warten
und das wird ein thema sein in dieser
vorlesung also zum beispiel wird es
später so etwas geben was für logische
gesetze nennen werden und das sind sätze
die nicht falsch sein können ja die war
sind egal in welchem gebiet sie
auftreten würden
das sind dann logische gesetze und das
sind solche allgemeinen gesetze des
rasens die pflege hier im kopf hat
ich bin überzeugt dass wir in einer
durchaus endgültigen wendungen der
philosophie mitten darin stehen und dass
wir sachlich berechtigt sind den
unfruchtbaren streit der systeme als
beendet anzusehen
ja das ist so ein echo von leibnitz zwei
philosophen die sich streiten
man verwendet logik um den streit zu
schlichten mehr wer hat recht
die gegenwart ist so behaupte ich
bereits im besitz der mittel die jeden
derartigen streit im prinzip unnötig
machen
es kommt nur darauf an sie entschlossen
anzuwenden
diese mittel sind in aller stille
unbemerkt von der mehrzahl der
philosophischen lehrer und
schriftsteller geschaffen worden
und so hat sich eine lage gebildet die
mit allen früheren unvergleichbar ist
dass die lage wirklich einzigartig und
die eingetretene wendung wirklich
endgültig ist kann nur eingesehen werden
indem man sich mit den neuen wegen
bekannt macht und von dem standpunkte zu
dem sie führen auf alle die bestrebungen
zurückschaut die je als philosophische
gegolten haben
die wege gehen von der logik aus das ist
jetzt 20 jahrhundert schon die moderne
logik ist bereits entwickelt worden und
das was schlick hier einer der begründer
des wiener kreises des logischen
empirismus ja einer wichtigen strömung
der philosophie und zwanzigsten
jahrhundert was schlick hier schreibt
ist was die philosophen tun sollen ist
sie sollen diese neuen mittel der logik
die entwickelt wurden
an wänden in der philosophie und wände
das konsequent tun wird es zu einer
revolution in der philosophie kommen
wir werden philosophieren können auf
einem niveau das bis jetzt unbekannt war
das ist das poststück hier schreibt
später erschossen worden
aber nicht deshalb
und in der tat ist logik wenn sie so
wollen die intellektuelle
erfolgsgeschichte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
was denken sie sich klar sagte das ist
jetzt eine vorlesung
deshalb wäre es gleich nachweisen
zum jahre 2000 hin gab es zur rankings
zum beispiel in time magazine und da
ging es immer darum was weiß ich
physiker größter physiker oder größte
physikerin des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
ja was sind die top ten wissenschaftler
in dem gebiet zu gewesen im letzten jahr
unter und der gleich und in der
mathematik war der mathematiker des
jahrhunderts dieser herr her und das ist
kurt gödel oder auf amerikanisch google
aber kurt gödel österreicher übrigens
ich bin auch österreicher unter anderem
werde ich diese vorlesung nützen sie in
einige feinheiten österreichischer
sprache einzuführen
die erste haben sie bereits kennen
gelernt mathematik nicht mathematik
mathematik mathematiker des jahrhunderts
kurt gödel
und sie sehen hier erwähnt die turn
talent mathematik sei nicht sehr fein
hätte ponys famous incomplete
investieren und das ist ein satz
eigentlich sind 22 unvollständigkeit
sätze haben sie vielleicht schon mal
gehört die gehören zu den berühmtesten
logischen resultaten in der ersten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
gehörte zeigt darin im wesentlichen dass
die moderne mathematik nicht vollständig
akklimatisiert werden kann
das heißt sie können die mathematik
niemals als ganzes sozusagen durch
aktionen und regeln vollständig
festlegen oder beschreiben
egal wie sie das versuchen es wird ihnen
immer irgendeine mathematische wahrheit
entgehen
kurz gesagt gürtel war logica und ist
der größte mathematiker des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts laut time magazine
größter philosoph des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
der wittgenstein
auch österreicher
sie begann bei try to reduce romantics
zu logic endet bei finding the physics
zu benutzen
also was hier steht da gibt es gab
dieses berühmte buch von wittgenstein
der tractatus logik philosophie kuss und
einer der punkte der hier erwähnt wird
in diesem buch war zu zeigen dass sich
letztlich die gesamte mathematik
zurückführen lässt auf die logik ja also
wenn die mathematiker von zahlentheorie
sprechen sprechen die eigentlich ohne es
zu merken über logische zusammenhänge
oder logische gesetze das ist einer der
punkte im tractatus berühmtester
philosoph des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
wittgenstein und sagen wir mal ganz
locker ein logica stimmte mich nicht so
ganz
und ich finde es gibt doch ziemlich viel
nonsens dass der von wittgenstein kommt
ok
computerwissenschaftler informatiker des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts alan turing ja
kein österreicher macht nichts weil das
problem in vielen artikeln logic imagine
the machine that could make jungen
reasoning sound familie also auf tuning
die den wesentlichen das intellektuelle
konzept unseres modernen computers
zurück und dieses konzept unseres
modernen computers geht zurück auf logik
und logik ist die vorlesung der
situation also informatiker des
jahrhunderts alan turing logica das
meine ich mit intellektueller
erfolgsgeschichte wir gehen ein paar
jahre zurück es ist anfang oktober 2010
hannes leitgeb der im begriff ist nach
münchen umzuziehen das entspricht der
wahrheit über das ja ob die restliche
geschichte war es sage ich ihnen nicht
alles leid gibt er im begriff ist nach
münchen umzuziehen trifft herrn g t für
philosoph auf der straße
hallo nichts hallo auf blickend hallo
entschuldige bitte ich war gerade am
philosophischen grübeln die welt ist zu
tun
philosophisch weißt du naja vielleicht
weißt du das auch nicht ich habe gehört
dass du nach münchen gehst hast du dich
schon eingerichtet wie steht es mit
deinem büro ich alles noch in arbeit
nichts ist in meinem büro nichts ist in
meinem sekretariat was das nichts ist in
deinem büro wo das ist ja zum fürchten
und wie geht denn das überhaupt nichts
ist doch auch in deinem sekretariat
ich schließe das nichts kann zugleich an
zwei verschiedenen orten sein und wenn
nichts in seinem büro ist dann folgt
doch auch das zumindest etwas in deinem
büro ist es ist also zugleich nichts und
etwas in deinem büro und das ist alles
und warum
logische repräsentieren dass wir unser
erstes großes thema sein wenn wir mit
dem blog aussagen logl beginnen wenn du
nichts ist in meinem büro und nichts ist
in meinem sekretariat richtig logisch
repräsentiert wirst du merken dass es
nicht von derselben logischen form ist
wie sagen wir der tisch ist in meinem
büro sondern vielmehr nur soviel heißt
wie es ist nicht der fall dass etwas in
meinem büro ist es ist nicht der fall
dass etwas in meinem sekretariat ist
okay so was ich hier den p versuche mit
zu geben ist man muss unterscheiden
zwischen der sozusagen oberflächlichen
forum natur sprachlicher setzte und der
tiefer liegenden logischen form dieser
setzte auf den ersten blick scheint der
tisch ist in meinem büro dieser satz und
der satz nichts ist in meinem büro von
derselben form zu sein
ja also die wehren sich irgendwie gleich
an haben dieselbe abfolge von worten ja
der tisch entspricht nichts und so
weiter wenn man dabei die tiefere
logische form dieser setzte anschaut so
kommt man drauf eigentlich sind diese
sätze völlig unterschiedlich
strukturiert während der tisch ist in
meinem büro von einem objekt in der welt
sagt das ist eine gewisse eigenschaft
hat nämlich in meinem büro zu sein ist
der satz nichts ist in meinem büro von
einer anderen logischen form
das ist ein vereintes ein negation satz
wie wir das bald nennen werden das ist
ein satz von der form beginnt mit es ist
nicht der fall dass und dann kommt etwas
nämlich etwas ist in meinem büro
es ist nicht der fall dass etwas in
meinem büro ist das ist eine ganz andere
form als der tisch ist in meinem büro ja
in diesem satz kommt ein migrations
zeichen für eine vereinigung in anderen
satz nicht und das ist entscheidend
und wenn man das erkannt hat
vermeidet man die logischen
verwicklungen in die sich der p sofort
hineingeredet hat ja nichts ist
überhaupt kein name für ein objekt und
schon gar nicht für ein objekt das an
zwei verschiedenen orten zugleich sein
könnte und weil nichts kein name für ein
objekt ist kann man auch nicht aus
nichts ist in meinem büro folgern dass
etwas in meinem büro ist ja aus der
tisch ist in meinem büro kann man
folgern etwas ist im büro aber aus es
ist nicht der fall dass etwas im büro
ist kann man nicht folgern dass etwas im
büro ist im gegenteil diese zwei sätze
widersprechen sich
das kann nicht der fall sein dass nicht
alle gleichermaßen basis
dann bin ich ja beruhigt hat sehen
weiter ich nichts ist da also in meinem
büro
nichts ist die mine im sekretariat wenn
mein alter schreibtisch von daheim mit
dem lastwagen geliefert wird dann stelle
ich ihnen in meinem büro tee moment das
ist sehr interessant
sagen wir er wird geliefert nach dem was
du sagst wird dann einerseits dein
schreibtisch mit dem lastwagen geliefert
andererseits stellst du in dein büro der
schreibtisch hat also diese zwei
eigenschaften mit dem lastwagen
geliefert zu werden und von dir in
deinem büro bestellt zu werden
aber wie kann er denn diese beiden
eigenschaften zugleich haben
einerseits werde mit dem lastwagen herum
andererseits schiebst du ihn ins büro
hinein
aha ich verstehe der schreibtisch hat
zueinander widersprüchliche
eigenschaften
darin drückt sich wohl die veränderung
das werten aus dinge die sich verändern
haben widersprüchliche eigenschaften
aber letztlich verändert sich doch alles
also hat alles widersprüchliche
eigenschaften
das erinnert mich an meine
habilitationsschrift in der ich meine da
schreibt mich hat diese eigenschaften
gar nicht zugleich genauer wird mit dem
lastwagen geliefert drückt gar keine
eigenschaft aus ein ähnlicher punkt wie
vorher nur geht es jetzt um andere
logische formen
ja das was dem p hier verwirrt hat ist
man scheint auf den ersten blick ein und
demselben gegenstand zwei
unterschiedliche vielleicht sogar
konflikt ihre eigenschaften
zuzuschreiben
auf dem zweiten blick erkennt man jedoch
dass die logische form dieser
sprachlichen ausdrücke dieser setzte der
natur sprache anders ist
eigentlich ist es so dass hier
stillschweigend gar keine eigenschaften
ausgedrückt werden sondern beziehungen
und zwar müsste man eigentlich wenn man
ganz präzise ist sagen dass ein und
derselbe gegenstand zu einem zeitpunkt
eine gewisse eigenschaft hat ja zu einem
anderen zeitpunkt aber nicht und wenn
man diese eigenen diese zeit punkte
hinzu rechnet dann geht es eigentlich
gar nicht mehr am eigenschaften sondern
und beziehungen ja der tisch steht in
einer bestimmten beziehung zu einem
zeitpunkt steht aber vielleicht nicht in
derselben beziehung zu einem anderen
zeitpunkt ja sozusagen der tisch ist im
büro ist eigentlich unvollständig man
müsste sagen der tisch ist im büro zu
dem zeitpunkt team ja also im büro sein
ist eigentlich keine eigenschaft sondern
eine beziehung eine relation ein ding
ist an einem bestimmten ort zb im büro
zu einem zeitpunkt und das ist eine
beziehung zwischen dem ding und dem
zeitpunkt
und wenn sie den zeitpunkt verändern
also von einem zeitpunkt zu einem
zeitpunkt strich übergehen ja dann ist
nicht garantiert dass diese beziehung
aufrechterhalten bleibt
er hat der tisch kann zum beispiel zum
zeitpunkt im büro sein zu einem anderen
zeitpunkt aber eben nicht dann steht er
in dieser beziehung im büro sein
zu dem ersten zeitpunkt auch nicht zu
dem 2 wenn man diesen zeitpunkt ja
vergisst wenn man sich nicht klar
darüber wird dass diese bezugnahme auf
den zeitpunkt zur logischen formen
dieser sätze gehört dann verhält man
sich sofort in diese philosophischen
schwierigkeiten wie kann dann ein gingen
gleichzeitig eigenschaft p haben und die
eigenschaft nicht p und was ist hier los
man muss erkennen dass es hier
eigentlich gar keine eigenschaften gibt
von einer eigenschaft könnte man erst
reden wenn dieser parameter hier
eingefüllt wurde
wenn man sagt nein ich fokussiere mich
jetzt auf einen ganz bestimmten
zeitpunkt ja deshalb das datum die und
die stunde die und die minute dann wenn
das angefüllt ist dann ist der tisch
einfach in meinem büro oder nicht zudem
zeitungen genauso drückt stelle ich ins
büro keine eigenschaft aus weil man
wiederum hin zu sagen muss wann ich
dieses und jenes ins büro stelle was ich
vorher meinte war selbstverständlich nur
wenn mein schreibtisch zum zeitpunkt t
mit dem lastwagen geliefert wird dann
stelle ich ihn zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt t strich in meinem büro und
wenn man diese zwei unterschiedlichen
zeitpunkten miteinander vermischt und
sich nicht klar ist über diesen
unterschied dann kommt man in diese
verwicklungen
es ist auch gar nicht widersprüchlich zu
einem zeitpunkt mit dem lastwagen
geliefert zu werden und zu einem anderen
zeitpunkt von mir ins büro gestellt zu
werden
selbiges gilt übrigens genau genommen
auch für die vorgesetzte nichts ist in
meinem büro und nichts ist in meinem
sekretariat zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt ist nichts in meinem büro und
zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt ist nichts
in meinem sekretariat man lässt diese
zeitliche relativierungen in der
natürliche sprache nur oft weg aber in
der eigentlichen logischen form dieser
sätze sind dieselben selbstverständlich
vorhanden
im übrigen sobald man sich dieses
punktes mal gewahr geworden ist ist es
auch wieder ganz in ordnung in gewissen
kontexten dieser zeit punkte weg zu
lassen
ja wenn man einmal verstanden worum es
geht wird man nicht in diese
verwicklungen hinein laufen und kann
vereinfachen und das tut man auch
ständig in den wissenschaften
es ist ziemlich klar in welchem
zeitpunkt es geht also an wen ich ihn
nicht hinzu aber es ist wichtig sich
einmal wenigstens klar gemacht zu haben
dass diese bezugnahme auf den zeitpunkt
wichtig sein kann
und wenn sie jetzt an zu wissenschaften
denken wir die physik dann ist diese
bezugnahme auf zeitpunkt der essenzielle
wenn da irgendein allem im ballon hoch
steigt ja und dann von der ganz oben
runter springt auf die erde
auch ein österreicher und sie wollen das
physikalisch beschreiben dann wollen sie
sagen zu welchem zeitpunkt sich dieses
objekt an welchen ort gefunden hat sie
wollen diese raum zeitliche dreieck zu
beschreiben
und das geht nur von von vornherein
durch explizite bezugnahme auf orte und
zeitpunkt ja also wenn sie diese
bezugnahme aus der physik rausnehmen
würden wird die gesamte physik
zusammenbrechen überhaupt keinen sinn
machen also dort ist es ganz klar wir
müssen das explizit machen
in der natürliche sprache kann man sich
manchmal leisten diese bezugnahme zu
vergessen
aber was sie als besucher lernen sollten
ist dass sie im prinzip stehen
schweigend da ist und das ist sie
jederzeit sozusagen aus dem hut zaubern
können um philosophische verwicklungen
zu vermeiden das ist schade eigentlich
sagt ap
ich war gerade dabei ein paar tiefe
einsichten in die welt zu gewinnen
nur scheinbar lassen wir das ziel weiter
nichts ist in meinem büro nichts ist in
meinem sekretariat wenn man alter
schreibtisch von daheim mit dem
lastwagen geliefert wird dann stelle ich
ihnen in meinem büro angenommen ich
stelle ihn in meinem büro
okay was heißt angenommen du hast doch
gerade gesagt dass du nun dein büro
stellen wirst ich habe nur gesagt wenn
er mit dem lastwagen geliefert wird dann
stelle ich ihnen in meinem büro
ja das ist so ein typischer wenn dann
satz hier und diese wenn dann setzte
finden sie überall in der alltagssprache
in den wissenschaften und natürlich in
der philosophie in der philosophie wird
ständig darum zu gehen dass man
irgendwelche annahmen trifft ja in der
metaphysik oder in der kenntnis theorie
oder in der ethik und dann unter diesen
annahmen gewisse schlüsse zieht und das
wird typischerweise geregelt durch
gewisse wenn dann setzte und logische
regeln die auf diesen ländern operiert
also das wird ein wichtiges thema werden
wenn er nicht mit dem lastwagen
geliefert wird
dann stelle ich ihn vielleicht gar nicht
in meinem wirkung das ding ist nämlich
schwierig zu transportieren
also wenn mein alter schreibtisch von
daheim mit dem lastwagen geliefert wird
dann stelle ich ihnen in meinem büro
angenommen ich stelle ihn in mein büro
triumphierend dann muss es der fall sein
dass er mit dem lastwagen geliefert
worden ist eigentlich nicht warum genau
genau also der wenn dann sagt so was wie
wenn a eintritt dann tritt auch b 1
ja wenn der fall ist dann ist auch
wieder fallen aber es war okay
und dann hat man die informationen bei
angenommen also der anteil ist
eingetreten der pi möchte es auf den
wellen teil auf das erschließen
aber wie der kollege richtig bemerkt hat
es könnte ja auch andere gründe geben
warum dieses b eingetreten ist stimmt
der as sachverhalt würde zudem die
sachwalter der b sachverhalt ist
eingetreten
aber es könnte ja auch einen zeh
sachverhalt geben der auch dorthin führt
und in der tat ist dieser sachverhalt
eingetreten und nicht der fall also aus
wenn adam b&b dürfen sie nicht
notwendigerweise auf anschließen es
könnte schiefgehen du darfst zwar aus
wenn man alter schreibtisch von daheim
mit dem lastwagen geliefert wird dann
stelle ich ihnen in meinem büro und mein
alter schreibtisch von daheim ist mit
dem lastwagen geliefert worden folgern
dass ich den schreibtisch in mein büro
stelle das ist in ordnung
das ist ein anderer schluss das ist der
schluss von wenn adam b
daher b das ist in ordnung ja das ist
eine berühmte logische regeln die wir in
bälde modus polenz nennen werden das
höchst einsichtig aber du darfst nicht
aus wenn mein alter schreibtisch von
daheim mit dem lastwagen geliefert wird
dann stelle ich ihnen mein büro wenn
adam g
und ich stelle meinen alten schreibtisch
von daheim in meinem büro das sb der
anteil folgern dass man alter
schreibtisch von daheim mit dem
lastwagen geliefert worden ist
wenn adern b&b daher ist logisch
ungültig so werden wir das bisschen
später nennen
das heißt es könnte potenziell dabei was
schief gehen
es ist möglich dass die annahmen alle
wahr sind
die kompression aber falsch ist ja und
das beschreibe ich hier also zum
beispiel was wäre denn wenn beim
schreibtisch wieder im großen pkw
geliefert worden wäre wenn adam bösz
gegessen ja halt mal fest akzeptiert der
b teil tritt ein mann schreibtisch wird
geliefert kommt in mein büro aber derart
teil ist gar nicht eingetreten ja ist
nicht geliefert werden mit diesem
lastwagen sondern eben mit einem großen
pkws hat einen anderen grund gegeben für
das b das wird so ein fall wenn adam b
vielleicht war es ja schon akzeptiert bh
ist aber falsch ist und dass der ganze
schluss den der p durchführen wollte ist
nicht logisch gültig bei dem logisch
gültigen schluss darf es nicht zu sein
dass man aus lauter waren annahmen zu
einer falschen prämisse kommen kann und
das wird uns noch ausführlich
beschäftigen
sie können sich vorstellen wenn sie
philosophie betreiben wollen oder auch
wissenschaft dann werden sie das
hoffentlich tun auf basis von logisch
gültigen argumenten ja wo diese art von
folgerung aus fehlern eben nicht
eintreten
ich wollte nicht unterbrechen
du wolltest sagen angenommen ich stelle
ihnen mein büro stelle ich ihn dann vom
eingang aus gesehen links oder rechts
die frage ist jetzt aber keine
philosophische frage ich verwundert
natürlich nicht ich erzähle doch nur von
meinem zukünftigen büro ph jetzt wird es
aber doch philosophisch sein zukünftiges
büro wie kannst du denn jetzt von etwas
erzählen dass es erst in der zukunft
geben wird
das hieße doch es jetzt etwa
das ist jetzt noch gar nicht gibt ich
möchte da gleich noch einmal
zurückkommen auf meine frühere idee dass
werden und das ist ein ähnlicher punkten
wie vorher
ja es ist völlig in ordnung über dinge
zu reden die vielleicht in der zukunft
stattfinden
genauso wie sie in ordnung ist über
dinge zu reden die in der vergangenheit
stattgefunden haben ja und wenn man es
richtig macht und wie man das macht
lernen sie dann führt das auch nicht zu
irgendwelchen philosophischen
verwirrungen und das beschreibe ich hier
ja logisch betrachtet gibt es nur etwas
das diese und jene eigenschaften hat
oder es gibt so etwas eben nicht
es gibt zum beispiel ein büro des herrn
hannes leitgeb welches sagen wir mit dem
zwölfter november 2010 vom bezogen wird
das war auch richtig sehe dann bis zum
zeitpunkt meiner pensionierung mehr oder
weniger unverändert bleibt und mit dem
zeitpunkt meiner pensionierung von
meinem nachfolger oder einer
nachfolgerin auseinander genommen wird
ich kann jetzt von diesem meinem büro
sprechen so wie von allen anderen dingen
die zu bestimmten zeitpunkten bestimmte
eigenschaften haben sprechen kann
das war der punkt schon vorher ja dinge
haben zu bestimmten zeitpunkten gewisse
eigenschaften und auch wenn ein ding
erst in der zukunft der zu einem
zukünftigen zeitpunkt gewisse
eigenschaften haben wird kann ich diesen
dingen und diesem zeitpunkt schon jetzt
ihre beziehung zueinander zu sprechen
daran ist überhaupt nix schief ist
nein es gibt jetzt etwas das es jetzt
noch gar nicht gibt ist nicht ganz
präzise formuliert was du eigentlich
meinst es nur es gibt etwas das vom
zwölfter november 2010 bis zum zeitpunkt
meiner pensionierung mein büro ist also
in einer bestimmten beziehung zu mir
steht zu mir sagen ja und außerdem ist
es der fall dass das heutige datum vor
dem zwölften november 2010 liegt das ist
alles also der zeitpunkt zu dem die
reden liegt halt vor diesem november
zeitpunkt ja aber da man es nicht
seltsam ist ja der eine zeitpunkt es vor
dem anderen und zudem letzteren passiert
irgendwas und von dem letzteren bis zu
meiner pensionierung passiert das und so
weiter unproblematisch da und daran ist
doch gar nichts bedenklich du kannst
doch auch von aristoteles reden obwohl
er bereits 322 vor christus verstorben
ist aristoteles hat die eigenschaft von
384 bis 322 vor christus gelebt zu haben
das kann ich doch jetzt sagen über den
aristoteles und dieser zeitpunkt
bestimmt von aristoteles möchte ich
eigentlich schon reden können
ich bin ja ein fluch trotzdem beunruhigt
mich das was es ist doch so aristoteles
hat am 18 oktober 380 vor christus um 9
uhr morgens in der nase gebohrt oder
aristoteles hat am 18 oktober 380 vor
christus um 9 uhr morgens nicht in der
nase gebohrt ich natürlich dieser satz
ist wie die logica sagen logisch war das
ist einer von diesen gesetzen nicht das
interessanteste okay zugegeben aber als
eins von diesen logischen gesetzen die
vorher erwähnt hatte dieser satz ist
zwar rein aufgrund der bedeutung der
ausdrücke oder und nicht der ist einfach
von der form oder nicht das ist hier die
frage
da oder nicht an dass der satz war es
liegt nicht an dem das irgendwas mit
aristoteles und nase bohren zu tun hat
dass der satz war ist und in der tat war
sein muss
liegt daran dass der satz auf spezielle
weise mittels dieser wörter oder um
nicht zusammengebaut wurde ja also auch
wenn sie für das einen ganz anderen satz
vielleicht über den platten oder so
einsetzen wird der resultierende satz
wenn er diese form a oder nicht hat
immer noch als wahr heraus kommen 2 p
jetzt kommt der punkt der ein verwirrter
aber wenn es keine zeit reisen gibt dann
ist es doch vermutlich so dass wir
niemals herausfinden können ob
aristoteles nun am 18 oktober 380 vor
christus um 9 uhr morgens in der nase
gebohrt hat oder nicht gut ja ist das
nicht ein problem gar nicht es ist doch
nur so dass es entweder war ist das
aristoteles zu dem zeitpunkt der nase
gebohrt hat oder dass dies falsch ist
aber etwas kann durchaus wahr oder
falsch seien ohne dass wir herausfinden
können welche der beiden alternativen
eintritt oder eingetreten ist und in der
logik geht es nicht primär darum
herauszufinden ob ein bestimmter satz
wahr ist oder nicht sondern es geht
darum festzustellen ob einsatz überhaupt
falsch sein könnte
das ist zum beispiel interessant das
geht in der logik eher darum
herauszufinden aus welchem setzen andere
sätze folgen das heißt wenn die wahl
sind muss dieser andere satz wasser aber
logik ist kein allgemeines werkzeug und
von jedem satz feststellen zu können ob
das wahr oder falsch ist das wäre
verrückt wenn logik so einfach wäre
dann hörte die logik alle anderen
wissenschaftsgebiete aufsaugen ja also
zum beispiel mathematiker sind
interessiert festzustellen welche
mathematischen setzte wahnsinn welche
nicht wenn das jetzt teil der logik wäre
dann sind die alle arbeitslos die
physiker wollen feststellen von gewissen
setzen physikalische setzen ob sie wahr
oder falsch sind
wenn das teil der logik wäre auch
arbeitslos das kann nicht sein sondern
wenden sie sich an die zitate vorher
logik ist das was alle diese gebiete
sozusagen gemein haben
das wird uns
und da allgemeinere philosophische
punkte ist wahrheit und falschheit ist
nicht dasselbe wie für wahr halten oder
für falsch halten
ja also es ist immer eine person die
etwas für war oder für falsch hält zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt aber wahr und
falsch haben nicht diese gleiche
qualifikation auf eine person hin oder
einem zeitpunkt hin wenn der satz mal
vollständig da steht dann wird der satz
einfach wahr sein oder er wird nicht
wahr sein das heißt falsch sein wenn es
ein aussage satz ist aber er wird nicht
wahr sein relativ zu der person und
falsch zu einer anderen person und er
wird auch nicht wahr sein relativ zu dem
zeitpunkt oder falsch zu einem anderen
zeitpunkt setzte sind einfach wahr oder
falsch aber es sind personen die zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt etwas für
wahr halten oder für falsch halten und
herausfinden was war es hat zu tun mit
für wahr halten und falsch halten es
sind personen die was herausfinden
einsatz war falsch ist hat nichts mit
der person zu tun und nichts mit dem er
aus finden von wahrheit und falschheit
ok und in der logik wird ausschließlich
um wahrheit und falschheit gehen und
nicht um die person glaubt dass weiß
dass hält für war das und so weiter das
ist auch interessant aber das gehört
woanders hin nämlich in die
erkenntnistheorie in der
erkenntnistheorie geht es genau um
solche fragen was ist wissen was ist
rationalität was ist gerechtfertigt es
für wahr halten ja da geht es darum wie
personen sich relativ zur wahrheit
verhalten aber in der logik geht es um
die wahrheit selbst
es ist wahr dass am mars auf den
koordinaten soundso ein grüner stein mit
einem durchmesser von einem meter liegt
oder aber das ist falsch
dies ist gar so ganz unabhängig davon
was wir darüber wissen oder was wir
darüber wissen können ja also entweder
liegt dieser stein von dieser art an
dieser koordinaten oder eben nicht
aber wir wissen es nicht ja vielleicht
ist es wird es uns auch praktisch nie
möglich sein das herauszufinden
ja könnte sein und trotzdem ist es so
der stein liegt dort oder nicht der satz
es war oder eher sinn falsch wahrheit
ist etwas anderes als wissen oder wissen
ich sehe was du meinst einverstanden
aber hat aristoteles nun am 18
oktober 380 vor christus um 9 uhr
morgens in der nase gebohrt ich keine
ahnung wie soll ich das wissen das ist
auch gar keine philosophische frage
sondern eine empirische davon solltest
du die finger lassen
ja der philosophie geht es ja wie gesagt
um apriori erkenntnisse obwohl sein
neues gebiet gibt das nennt sich
experimentelle philosophen extra wenn
sie das interessiert googeln sie doch
mal extra also ich strich fiel mit ph
aber das ist die ausnahme nicht die
regel ja
dazu kommen in bälde aber wenn ich zu
ihm gesagt ritze fritz und dann sage ich
zu ihnen ist der etwa falsch dann werden
sie mir zurecht entgegenhalten moment
dazu müsste erstmal sinnvoll sein eine
bedeutung haben wohl geformt sein
ich muss ihn verstehen können dann
können wir uns darüber unterhalten ob
der satz auch war es also die welt
richtig beschreibt sozusagen oder falsch
ist die welt nicht richtig beschreiben
aber christen fritz beschreibt überhaupt
nicht der ist nicht sinnvoll und daher
kann man von dem ding dann auch nicht
sinnvoll sagen dass er wahr oder falsch
ist ja könnte
gute gute frage also ihre frage ist
nehmen wir wieder so etwas hier mit a
oder nicht da und jetzt gesagt egal was
sie da einfüllen da kommt was wahres
raus und jetzt wollen sie für irgendwas
einfüllen was komisch klingen wird
letztlich ja zb ein gänseblümchen worte
zu dem zeitpunkt der nase oder eben
nicht
frage ist der satz war ja und die
antwort wird sein man muss zuerst einmal
feststellen was sowas ist es überhaupt
ein aussage satz also ist
grammatikalisch richtig geformt
ja und dann kommen noch ein paar so
komponenten dazu und die werden uns in
bälde beschäftigen schon nächste woche
und wenn dieser test sozusagen bestanden
wird ja es handelt sich um einen aussage
satz einen deskriptive satz ein
dekoratives ja dann ist die antwort wenn
sie solch einen satz einfüllen für das
dann kommt aber nicht da im haus war aus
wenn sie auf was einfüllen was diesem
test sozusagen nicht besteht dann kommt
überhaupt gar kein aussage satz raus das
heißt es kommt überhaupt nichts raus von
denen man sinnvollerweise sagen könnte
es ist wahr oder falsch was ist jetzt
ein gänseblümchen da gibt es zwei
varianten die eine variante ist sie
sagen moment also von einem
gänseblümchen auszusagen
das ist in der nase bohrt ist schon
sinnlos das zwar grammatikalisch wenn
man es richtig hin schreibt in ordnung
aber inhaltlich sinnlos daher ist das
ganze konstrukt gänseblümchen bohrt in
der nase oder nicht kein aussage satz
man kann von ihm nicht sinnvoll sagen er
sei wahr oder falsch
daher ist das kein so ein satz den ich
vorher gemeint hat weil ich habe gemeint
oder nicht aber ein aussage satz ist
okay zweite variante
das ist die tolerantere man sagt das
gänseblümchen hat zudem an dem zeitpunkt
in der nase gebohrt ist schlichtweg
falsch
schauen sie sind auf das gänseblümchen
der das tut allerlei ja bewegt sich im
wind und wird gepflückt und so er aber
ist es nicht das board nicht in der nase
also ist das einfach falsch
das was hier passiert ist also einsatz
davor mag oder nicht da gänseblümchen
bohrt in der nase oder nicht und sie
fügen für das einen satz 1 einen aussage
satz ja von dem kann man sinnvoll
wahrheit oder falschheit sozusagen
aussagen
sie fügen einen speziellen aussage sagt
seien nämlich einen falschen da steht ja
quasi so was mich falsch oder nicht
falsch und dieses ganze konstrukt ist
dann war zwangsläufig
es gibt zwei mögliche antworten und die
hängen davon ab ob sie das gänseblümchen
bohrt in der nase zu dem zeitpunkt
überhaupt das aussehen oder nicht und
was die bessere variante ist da können
uns dann nächste woche darüber
unterhalten ok gute frage darf ich jetzt
endlich von meinem büro weiter erzählen
gerne
nichts ist in meinem büro nichts ist in
meinem sekretariat der damm angenommen
ich stelle ihn den schreibtisch in
meinem büro stelle ich ihnen dann vom
eingang aus gesehen links oder rechts
und p soll ich jetzt dazu sagen ob dies
wahr oder falsch ist noch verwundert wie
könntest du ich habe doch nur eine frage
gestellt fragen sind aber keine aussage
setzte anders ausgedrückt fragen sind
jeder war noch falsch ja das ist so
ähnlich wie das was wir gerade
diskutiert von einem frage satz kann man
nicht sinnvoll aussagen er sei wahr oder
falsch
der fällt gar nicht in die kategorie in
der man von wahrheit oder falschheit
sprechen möchte die sätze bei denen man
sehr wohl sinnvoll von ward oder
falscher sprechen möchte die werde ich
aussage setzen und in der gesamten
vorsaison logik 1 wird im wesentlichen
und aussage sätze gehen
warum das sind gerade die sätze mit
denen wir über die welt sprechen
in den naturwissenschaften im alltag
aber auch in der philosophie dass
sozusagen gewissem sinne für uns
wissenschaftler die wichtigste kategorie
von setzen
fragen sind auch wichtig ja klar aber
letztlich wenn sie ihren artikel
veröffentlichen wollen um den nobelpreis
zu bekommen ist das ein artikel mit
aussage setzen
aja und und noch etwas beschäftigt nicht
sag ich die ludwigstraße 31 ist das
gebäude in dem sich mein büro befinden
wird
das kann gar nicht sein das steht aber
doch in meinem vertrag in der sprache
der mathematiker ausgedrückt dazu
kapiert dass mich das beeindruckte in
der sprache der mathematiker ausgedrückt
hast du gerade behauptet ludwigstraße 31
ist gleich mit oder ist identisch mit
das gebäude in dem sich hannes leitgeb
büro befinden wird ganz genau
das kannst du aber gar nicht zu meinen
die linke seite dieser gleichung fängt
ja mit einem elan wer die rechte seite
mit einem dick beginnt wie sollen die
beiden dann identisch sein
oder können verschiedene dinge identisch
zueinander sein
das bringt mich zu meinen früheren bitte
dich schon wieder
also was was geht hier schief beim p was
würden sie sagen ja
genau genau also links steht irgendwas
was sprachlich es und recht steht was
sprachlich es die szene anders aus ein
zwerg mit elan 1 fängt an mit dem aber
inhaltlich sind sie gleich und damit
meinen sie dass die dasselbe ding
bezeichnet
richtig geht auch in der mathematik
genau also wenn man sowas hin schreibt
wie eins plus eins ist gleich zwei steht
links und rechts vom ist gleichzeitig
etwas anderes aber inhaltlich spricht
man über dasselbe objekt ja ein und
dieselbe natürliche zahl genau richtig
und dasselbe passiert ja und das hat der
p natürlich wieder nicht kapiert der sud
und api ein und dasselbe ding kann doch
ohne weiteres mehrere namen haben ein
und dieselbe örtlichkeit kann zugleich
mit dem namen ludwig straße 31
und mit der kennzeichnung das gebäude in
dem sich hannes leitgeb büro befinden
wird bezeichnet werden
sie sehen übrigens auch dass man auch
ganz verschiedene weisen namen für
objekte bilden kann hier ludwigstraße 31
ist eine art eigenname sowie auch hannes
leitgeb ein eigenname ist die andere art
von namen hier ist kein eigenname also
hier ist kein keinen kontakt dahinter
wenn sie so wollen sondern man benennen
bei dieser zweiten weise hier in dieser
in dieser platzierung ein ding indem man
das ding beschreibt ja dann nahm er
alles leipzig beschreibt nicht sondern
der iss verbunden mit mir durch einen
takt während diese beschreibung hier
charakterisiert oder bezeichnete objekt
dadurch dass das objekt beschrieben wird
nämlich als dasjenige gebäude in dem
sich alles leid gibt's büro befinden
wird sollen gewissen zeitpunkt so weiter
ganz am ende der vorlesung werden wir
uns sogar speziell mit dieser art von
name auseinandersetzen und wir werden
diese namen kennzeichnungen und werden
dann ein bisschen logische analyse von
kennzeichnungen betreiben aber das ist
ganz am ende ja und will vielleicht
sogar gar nicht prüfungsrelevant mehr
sein
mein kleiner sohn heißt ja auch
sebastian und wir bezeichnen
dennoch manchmal mit allerlei spitznamen
was die der eine name die nicht
verwendet habe um über die örtlichkeit
zu sprechen die mich interessiert
beginnt mit einem l
der andere name mit einem d aber beide
namen beziehen sich auf dasselbe objekt
die gleichung sagt nicht aus dass die
namen identisch sind sondern dass das
was der eine name bezeichnet identisch
ist dem was der andere name bezeichnet
und damit wären wir uns
auseinandersetzen also sowohl in dem
aussagen logischen teil als auch in den
prädikaten logischen teil werden wir
etwas betreiben dass man es im antik
nennt und in der semantik geht es um die
beziehungen zwischen sprache und welt zb
die beziehung zwischen einem namen und
dem objekt dass der name bezeichnet
und da kann es durchaus sein dass wir es
mit einer sprache zu tun haben in der
zwei namen gibt ja die aber bezug nehmen
referieren auf ein und dasselbe objekt
in der welt und das bild an semantisch
festgelegt und das wirkt sich dann aus
in wahrheit werten von von setzen und so
weiter und so fort
aristoteles ist doch auch identisch mit
dem philosophischen lehre alexanders des
großen bestimmt das erzähle ich ja auch
meinen studenten
dennoch habe ich immer noch sorgen was
dennoch aristoteles ist der
philosophische lehre alexanders das
heißt aristoteles ist identisch dem
philosophischen lehre alexanders stimmt
ja eh aristoteles ist ein philosoph
heißt das dann
aristoteles ist identisch dem
philosophen also die idee ist harrys
tote lässt ist der philosophische lehre
alexanders heißt so viel wie aristoteles
ist identisch mit oder ist die denke
stehen philosophischen lehre alexanders
dann müsste doch auch sagt er
aristoteles ist ein philosoph heißen
dass aristoteles identisch ist dem
philosophen aha sagt er
das würde erklären warum aristoteles im
mittelalter als der philosoph bezeichnet
wurde
nur platon ist auch ein philosoph heißt
das dann
plateaus platon ist identisch dem
philosophen und wenn beide mit dem
philosophen identisch sind sind sie dann
nicht einander identisch bezeichnet
aristoteles dasselbe objekt die
plattform ist vielleicht alles eins und
natürlich nicht
du hast nur die logische form dieser
setzte missverstanden und hier ist der
punkt dieses einfache wort hier die s&t
ist ein punkt den ich vorher schon
angesprochen hatte er die natur
sprachliche form von setzen ist zu
unterscheiden von der logischen form
dieser sätze in natürliche sprache kann
vielleicht immer ein und dasselbe
sprachliche ausdruck verwendet werden zb
hier ist aber in der logischen sprache
könnte damit jeweils was ganz
unterschiedliches gemein sein und so ist
es hier zum beispiel ja man kann sagen
so wie vorhin hier aristoteles ist der
philosophische lehre alexanders und das
heißt dann so viel wie ist identisch mit
das ist eine beziehung zwischen zwei
objekte nämlich mit sich selbst
identisch zu sein oder von einem objekt
rente sie wollen mit sich selbst
identisch zu sein und identität ist eine
beziehung ist steht hier kurz für ist
identisch mit
man kann aber auch sagen aristoteles ist
ein philosoph und hier wird wieder der
ausdruck ist verwende war es auch mal
hier wirklich gemeint ist ist kein
identität satz keine gleichung wenn sie
so wollen sondern das was ausgedrückt
wird ist das ein ding aristoteles eine
eigenschaft hat nämlich philosoph zu
sein also der satz ist nicht von der
form blablabla ist identisch mit blah
blah blah ja und wenn man das nicht
erkennt kommt mal wieder in die
schwierigkeiten dieser p hatte also nur
weil nur natürliche sprache ist steht
heißt das noch lange nicht dass dem in
logischen repräsentieren oder in der
logischen formen ein und dasselbe
ausdruck gegenüber stehen wird
er hat die logische form von den sätzen
blablabla ist identisch mit und
blablabla ist etwas das die und die
eigenschaft hat sind unterschiedlich das
muss man auseinanderhalten
ja das ist richtig das zum beispiel ist
ein philosoph da hat man schon das
gefühl moment da wird eine eigenschaft
ausgedrückt und viele leute könnten
philosophie sein
das ist richtig das ist noch ein zusatz
problem das auch selbst der name wie
hannes leitgeb es gibt bestimmt noch
irgendwo ein handels leitgeb also da
muss man auch in der logische sprache
wären sozusagen die eigennamen wirklich
so sein dass man quasi sicher sagen kann
das ist genau mein ding gibt ja aber was
immer noch der fall ist ist auch wenn es
mehrere hannes leitgeb es gebe von der
sprachlichen form her sollte der name
hannes leitgeb ein name sein der auf ein
ding zeigen will
das könnte schiefgehen aber zumindest
ist der von einem von einem typ von
einem grammatikalischen typ der auf ein
ding zeichnen möchte während ein
philosoph oder philosoph ist von
vornherein vom typ her kein sprachlicher
ausdruck der auf ein ding zeigen möchte
sondern das ist ein ausdruck solche
ausdrücke werden wir prädikate nennen
eine art von ausdruck die eine
eigenschaft ausdrücken will also das was
vielen dingen gemeinsam ist und das ist
von einem anderen sprachlichen typ also
in bälde würde ich jetzt jede antwort
würde ich die antwort auf ihre frage zu
geben haben das leid gibt ja oder
aristoteles oder so das ist ein
singulärer und der ausdruck philosophie
ist ein genereller term oder ein
prädikat dies sind grammatikalisch zu
unterscheiden selbst in der logik nicht
nur in der natürliche sprache aber auch
in der logik und wenn man dass es sich
klar macht dann ist es so wenn da ist
steht und links und rechts stehen
singuläre damit dann muss identität
gemeinsam wären aber da ist steht und
links steht ein singulärer term zum
beispiel aristoteles und rechts steht
ein generell laternen zum beispiel ist
dein films hof oder ein philosoph dann
kann
was keine identität mehr sein weil
identität besteht zwischen dingen der
gleichen art denn sie wollen genau also
überhaupt sie sollten sich jetzt nicht
denken ja nicht denn das immer und ganz
nervös werden und woher genau darum geht
es ja in dieser vorlesung das zu lernen
also der erste teil der vorlesung
besteht nur darin sich klar darüber zu
werden was die logische form von setzen
ist und dann später kommt das noch mal
in der prädikaten logik ja ja
gute frage also das ist ein bisserl sayn
wittgenstein dieser gedanke wir werden
mit der grenze
ich würde sagen ja im prinzip kann man
sich mit hilfe von logischen kunst
sprachen von mängeln der natürliche
sprache befreien und zwar von mängel in
der deutschen sprache von mängeln in der
englischen sprache von mängeln der
französische brachte und so weiter auch
von mängeln in bestimmten
wissenschaftssprache zum beispiel ja
sobald sie logisch ausgebildet sind sind
sie in der lage sozusagen durch diese
sprachigen durchzusehen ihre logische
struktur festzustellen und sich dann
eine kunstsprache zu entwickeln die
nicht mehr befangen ist mit diesen
mengen und das ist der grund warum wir
dann in bälde mit jeder menge formalem
zeugs zu tun haben werden wir werden
unsere eigenen formalen sprachen bauen
die so konstruiert sind dass sie diese
mängel nicht mehr haben und dann wird
wichtig sein dass wir in der lage sind
natürliche sprachen mit menge zu
übersetzen in unsere formalen sprachen
ohne menge ja wenn man den schritt mal
gemacht habe man diese menge beseitigt
kann man in den formalen sprachen ganz
präzise sagen
unter welchen bedingungen ist
einsatzfahrer falsch was folgt aus einem
satz wann ist ein satz zu einem anderen
video sportlich und so weiter ja hallo
und logik transzendiert man eigentlich
alle diese natürliche sprachen die
vorgegeben sind
aber wie soll ich das denn da kennen in
beiden fällen steht einfach nur ist das
ist der grund warum in logik vorlesungen
eine symbolsprache eingeführt wird
in der das ist im aristoteles ist der
philosophische lehre alexanders klar
unterschieden ist vom ist in paris ist
ein philosoph die natürliche sprache
kann einen sonst zu leicht verwirren und
probleme schaffen wo eigentlich gar
keine sind
dazu ähnlich wie mit dem nichts das
beispiel von vorher
deswegen wird meine logik 1 vorlesung
auch ihrem ersten schwerpunkt auf das
thema logische repräsentieren legen
vielleicht sollte ich doch mal eine
logik vorlesung besuchen ich leicht
verzweifelt bitte was ist jetzt mit der
ludwigsstraße 31 die ludwigstraße 31 ist
das gebäude in dem sich mein büro
befinden würde aber die ludwigstraße 31
gilt auch als der ort an dem so seltsame
dinge wie logik und wissenschaftstheorie
beheimatet sind vor denen sich die
studenten angeblich verrichten werden
sie sich trauen mich in meinem
zukünftigen büro besuchen zu kommen
die werden schon zur ludwigstraße 31
kommen schon weil man dort auch zu
anderen lehrstühlen weitergehen kann
grinst
und dann mache ich so ein bisschen
werbung hier ja das können sie selber
durchlesen
das immer so peinlich aber wir haben
dieses coole center das munich center
for mathematical philosophy und das
haben wir 2010 gegründet und da geht es
im wesentlichen und die anwendung
logischer und mathematischer methoden in
der philosophie und zwar in allen
gebieten oder philosophie wenn sie das
interessiert einfach mal durch soja als
spaßvogel sie einfach mal im cmp unique
center for medical philosophie oder auch
den ganzen ausdruck dann kommen sie auch
unsere webseite und da gibt es
ressourcen dort für studierende und
kalender mit vorträgen und stoff waren
die leute arbeiten und dann wissen sie
was ich meine er beruhige dich
vielleicht komme ich ja auch mal
besuchen und mit ein bisschen glück kann
ich sogar einen studenten überreden mich
zu begleiten
das ist nett aber jetzt muss ich weiter
über die wirklich tiefen fragen
nachdenken senkt den kopf murmelt wenn
die studenten nebenher neid gibt büro in
die ludwigstraße 31 geben dass nichts
immer noch dort ist herrn leitgeb
schreibtisch herleitung schreibt das
symbol mit einem lastwagen geliefert als
auch in seinem büro geschoben wird und
zugleich aristoteles und platon der
philosoph sind verdrängen die studenten
das nichts aus dem büro bewegt es sich
dann weiter in den lastwagen oder war es
vielmehr immer schon dort und bin
vielleicht sogar ich einst mit
aristoteles und platon und verleiht geht
mit mir rede ich die ganze zeit mit mir
selbst ist das nichts das dann in dem
lastwagen sein wird identisch mit dem
nichts das jetzt in meinem bzw in der
historie des büro in der ludwigstraße 31
ist und das obwohl alles total es schon
tot ist ich aber nicht um ein fragen
nicht wahr oder falsch sind dann muss
ich dass sie doch auch gar nicht
beantworten
winkt und geht weg bis bald ist sie sich
dann in einer vorlesung wischt sich über
die stirn
das soll ihnen so ein bisschen einen
eindruck geben worum es in der logik
gehen wird aber keine sorge es wird
alles bisschen systematischer sein dass
ich das im dialog was sie mitnehmen
sollten für mittwoch ist eine der
grundlegenden aufgaben der vorlesung
wird darin bestehen die logische form
sprachliche ausdrücke herauszuarbeiten
festzustellen zb ob sich ob es sich bei
einem bestimmten satz natürliche sprache
um einen aussage satz handelt oder nicht
und wenn wir das geleistet haben wird es
darum gehen welche logischen
eigenschaften und welche logische
beziehungen solche aussage sätze haben
zum beispiel über einsatz logisch war es
so ein logisches gesetz oder ob aus
einem satz
ein anderer satz logisch folgt in dem
sinne dass wenn der einsatz war ist der
andere war sein muss und wenn sie an so
etwas denken die argumentation
dann geht es im prinzip ständig um diese
art von eigenschaften und beziehungen
ja wenn sie eine zeitung aufschlagen und
journalisten argumentieren dann sagen
die blablabla fall und daraus folgt dass
blablabla fall ist typischerweise dann
irgendeine kritik an einen politiker
oder so
genauso in den wissenschaften ja in den
wissenschaften wird natürlich
argumentiert genauso in der philosophie
es gibt keine philosophie ohne argumente
und wo argumente sind muss man sich
immer die frage stellen ist das ein
gutes argument oder ein schlechtes
argument und die beste form von argument
wir die sein wo ein argument logisch
gültig ist das heißt wo die prämissen
die annahmen in dem argument die
wahrheit der konklusion zwangsläufig mit
notwendigkeit erzwingen werden wo und
wann das der fall ist bei einem argument
das werden wir in dieser logik vorlesung
feststellen lernen
die logik ist das grundlegende werkzeug
das wir philosophen brauchen um
philosophische fragen genau und
unzweideutig formulieren zu können um
festlegen zu können unter welchen
bedingungen einsatz war ist um wichtige
philosophische begriffe definieren zu
können um argumente auf ihre gültigkeit
hin untersuchen zu können um
stillschweigen der voraussetzungen
philosophische argumente explizit machen
zu können um aus behauptungen auf
korrekte weise schlüsse ziehen zu können
um den einfachen modellen die
plausibilität von theorie überprüfen zu
können und mathematische methoden auf
philosophische fragestellungen anwendbar
machen zu können und um insgesamt auf
eine ähnliche weise fortschritte in der
philosophie erzielen zu können wie die
naturwissenschaften dies in ihren
wissenschaften leisten
kurz gesagt durch die logik lernt man
klar sprechen und klar denken und das
ist eine grundanforderung an jedem guten
philosophen und dann die gute
philosophie in diesem sinne bis mittwoch
danke
[Applaus]